on était sur nadia daam donc une
chroniqueuse d'europe 1 qui a taclé le
rappeur maître gims était hier matin
dans sa chronique quotidienne
elle parlait donc dû comme je voulais la
multiplication des activités culturelles
pour les enfants en bas âge et un moment
c'est pas pourquoi elle a mis un gros
tacle à maître gims il a rien fait le
pôle il était connu il était sapé comme
jamais il s'est fait fracasser regarder
faire écouter de la musique classique un
foetus augmentent sans cuit ce qui
évidemment aux faux c'est comme si on
disait que les enfants qui écoutent
maître gims ont un peu plus contre les
autres en fait ça si c'est vrai pour peu
qu'on ait les moyens
l'invité d'europe 1
[Musique]
voilà moi j'aime j'aime pas j'aime pas
de base quand on critique le travail
d'un accès gratuit et c'est vrai que
maître gims wallage cruxéens franchement
pour moi c'est un génie je vous dis
appris qu'on aime sa musique ou pas en
tout cas ce qu'il fait c'est énorme
gilles là c'est gratuit puis c'est mal
fait et en plus ce qui prouve l'état de
déliquescence d'europe ainsi attendus
dans une radio normalement qu'est ce qui
se passe dans ces cas là vous avez
maître gims qui arrivent et les réalités
de l'émission d'après mais ben vous
faites une rencontre elle vient
s'excuser elle vient discuter là rien
d'une sas
vraiment j'ai trouvé sa ruelle à lévis
pour tous vous lire parce que pardon un
minimum même de cohérence et à peine de
quoi ça n'arriverait jamais sur leurs
terres ah si il ya de la cohérence c'est
même plus du corporatisme serrer les
rangs c'est vrai que quand on fait des
chroniques humoristiques
oui mais la mélasse et on en fait tous
c'est pas d'après elle c'est vrai que
c'est pas la peine de vous l'apprendre y
y et sur sur rtl vous chez vous bah moi
ce qui me concerne moi non maintenant la
station fait ce qu'elle veut mais c'est
selon moi de vous déranger
elle fait toujours des effets faciles
c'est sa maman que je reprends ma voix